ce dimanche c'est la messe de rentrée de
la maîtrise de dijon c'est une tradition
mais cette année elle est bousculée par
la crise du court aux navires us pour
respecter la distanciation le coeur est
séparée en deux par rapport aux sombres
on va découvrir tout à l'heure à la
répétition et pendant le fit savoir si
ça fonctionnait avant l'arrivée des
maîtrises ya le chef de quart et
l'organiste font une dernière mise au
point avant une liturgie l'important de
calais les quelques moments où le grand
orgue qui se trouve quand même loin 50 m
de la maîtrise va devoir dialoguer ou
alterner avec le chanteur mathilde
verrier et l'organiste du choeur de la
cathédrale au plus près des maîtrisiens
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 120
choristes le grand choeur les élèves des
quatre niveaux du collège ainsi que le
jeune choeur et le choeur d'hommes les
6e 5e je vous écoute sur le premier
refrain à l'unisson uniquement vous sur
le deuxième couplet
une heure de répétition l'église
commence à se remplir pour l'office à
10h les maîtrisiens n'ont que quelques
minutes pour aller revêtir leurs
costumes liturgique aux vestiaires la
famille des maîtrisiens va s'agrandir
aujourd'hui les nouveaux essaye la capa
un vêtement qu'il leur sera remis par un
parrain ou une marraine faisant déjà
partie du coeur comme ça en prenait du
bon temps du lock outés ont normalement
le live effet rabat et tueur à gages sur
le même ton défi était le plus bas au
fond sur la gauche maîtrisant un jour
maîtrisiens toujours cette devise est
particulièrement vrai pour dominique
allain jules apporté de la maîtrise de
dison je suis rentré en 1962 la maîtrise
et j'ai fait mes études à la maîtrise
jusqu'au 3e et après j'ai continué à
chanter au choeur d'hommes
jusqu'à aujourd'hui voilà la médaille
que j'ai reçu de la part de l'archevêque
pour 50 ans de présence au coeur de la
maîtrise
[Musique]
lorsque la maîtrise a été fondé en 1895
par monseigneur moi ce n'est ce dernier
a souhaité mettre de la couleur dans les
pierres blanches et lumineuse de la
cathédrale
la maîtrise fête ses 125 ans cette année
enraciné dans l'histoire à la connu
l'interdiction du chant grégorien en
traverser les périodes de guerre alors
que beaucoup d'écoles maîtrisienne ont
disparu elle s'est adaptée aux
évolutions de la société devenue l'école
maîtrisienne régional en 1990 elle fait
partie du patrimoine dijonnais
il y a ceux qui entrent à la maîtrise et
ceux pour qui l'heure est venue de la
quitter
[Musique]
en espérant que les derniers mois passés
au collège les stomp pas tous les autres
souvenirs que vous avez matile sacha
virginie yacine merci viser la
perfection pour entente et l'auditoire
travail et gagner en confiance
un gage de réussite plébiscité par les
parents d'élèves
[Musique]
alors que la tenue ça apporte une
certaine certaine rigueur et c'est ça
qui est vraiment important pour moi pour
les enfants et puis le chance ça ouvre
beaucoup de choses c'est la maîtrise de
la musique et je trouve que c'est sa
porte énormément j'ai trois enfants qui
sont passés par la maîtrise de dijon
l'aîné des enfants à garder contact avec
tous ses anciens amis la maîtrise
voilà et je trouve que c'est une grande
chance pour pour eux nous ont fait des
kilomètres pour les accompagner jusqu
ici avec nous
on est très contents mieux faire la
célébration des cent vingt cinq ans de
la maîtrise se poursuit jusqu'en
novembre 2000 21 prochains grands rendez
vous en décembre 2020 pour les concerts
de noël